This week Donald Trump did something
that the political class actually LIKED.
Our troops will fight to win.
A New York Times reporter called this Trump's
best speech as President.
Politicians from both parties were suddenly happy.
I think there’ll be a lot of bipartisan support
in Congress for this proposal.
I am proud.
I am relieved.
The political class likes the idea
of a powerful President going to war.
That’s why I’m relieved
that there are at least a few people to say,
wait a second,
Afghanistan is now America’s longest war ever.
17 years.
More troops are NOT the answer.
Before Trump spoke,
I talked to one person who gets that.
You say America should get out
of Afghanistan and Iraq
Look, John,
next year in the budget we've got
$43 billion dollars in Afghanistan of military spending.
That's as much as Great Britain or Germany
or France spend on their entire military
we are going to pour down a rat hole in Afghanistan.
It's our 17th year of the war.
That means the year after next we will have troops
deploying to a war that started before
they were born.
It's the longest war American has ever had.
And it is bankrupting our country.
It's the graveyard of empires,
and we've spent trillions of dollars there.
There are other wars going on in Afghanistan.
We've spent $8 billion dollars on a war
against poppy seeds, against heroin, in Afghanistan.
In the period of time that we've spent
$8 billion dollars trying to reduce production
of poppy in Afghanistan,
they have doubled production.
I think if we would cut the spending that we're using
on the war against drugs in Afghanistan,
maybe they would cut production.
The reality is we're not even trying
to cut their production,
because it would disrupt their economy so much.
I asked the Inspector General,
could you spray Roundup,
you know, the stuff that kills weeds,
could you spray Roundup on those poppy fields?
Would that work?
He said, of course it would work.
It's a plant.
It's subject to herbicides.
It would die quickly.
I said, why don't we do it?
He said, It would be far too effective.
It would work instantly,
and it would disrupt their economy.
And it would agitate the Taliban,
who now generate revenue off of that.
If we pull out, people say
the Taliban will come back, Al Qaeda will come back.
We have to fight it over there
so they don't fight us over here.
The people that say
the Taliban will come back
need to acknowledge the Taliban never went away.
We built a hydroelectric dam there,
and 30% of the power goes to the Taliban.
We are not going to impose
a democratic republic on them.
It's not going to happen.
After 17 years, I think we need to acknowledge that.
In addition to the trillions of dollars
in military spending,
we've spent over a hundred billion dollars
on their infrastructure.
Our highway trust fund is $50 billion dollars a year.
For what we've spent in Afghanistan,
we could have doubled our highway trust fund for two
years in a row.
Think about what that would have done
for this country.